here's the thing about good interior
design
you know in your gut what was good you
also know in your gut what is ugly
so i believe that interior design should
be accessible to everyone so i want you
to learn how to enjoy the process and
how to make your home a true haven
if you're only going to decorate a few
rooms choose the rooms that matter the
most your bedroom should be an oasis it
should be a respite from the world
outside so splurge there we're going to
get into everything space planning how
to make effective mood boards how to
manipulate color patterns and textures
in a vivacious bold way
so let's say you're overwhelmed with how
do i get started i know it can be scary
i know it can be intimidating first wait
to paint
start small get that concept laid out
then pick out your paint colors you're
gonna save a lot of money and also a lot
of costly mistakes i had to learn that
through trial and error
lots of trials and lots of error
lighting is absolutely essential in
interior design and decoration it's
about figuring out the placement of the
furniture and then how does lighting
support that that placement
just because this bookcase is taking up
this wall does not mean that you should
subtract this wall from the opportunity
of featuring great artwork there's no
rhyme or reason or no rules it's all
about what looks good just keeping it
real but never forget the foundation
your hands your mind your heart and
physical samples my philosophy is that
while you're here we all deserve to live
the very best lives
possible you're worth the investment
i'm cory damon jenkins and this is my
master class
[Music]
you